So women are much happier if you look at
national polls than they were saying in
the late 19 fifties in early 19 sixties,
and I think that's partly because
freedom and happiness,
those are not the same thing.
They're not even close.
And now I see young women all the time
struggling to figure out what to do with
their lives because they have no idea
how to have a job slash career and a
family.
So.
And there's no answer to that.
It's a really difficult problem,
you know,
and there's all sorts of ideas.
Like I did a lot of consulting for law
firms for a long time about a decade and
I had a lot of clients who were
extremely high functioning female
lawyers,
younger ones trying to figure out how to
balance their career with their desire
to have a life.
And you know,
you hear all the time about women being
denied access to positions of power and
that's uh,
that's the consequences of prejudice and
oppression.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
Everything is caused by the same thing
first,
right?
You have got one causal principle.
Wonderful.
Now you're a philosopher.
You can figure out everything with it,
so like the law firms cannot keep their
women in their thirties.
They cannot keep them.
The big law firms,
they all leave.
Why?
Because the women hit 30.
They're brilliant.
Conscientious,
intelligent.
They were deadly in highschool,
deadly,
and university.
They nailed law school.
They whipped through there.
Articling,
they,
they made partner by the time they were
30 and it's like they're in a rocket to
the top position.
What do they find when they get their 80
hour work weeks?
Right?
Because that's one of the things you
want to think about.
You know,
you think that the people who run things
are sitting at home smoking big cigars
and like telling their minions what to
do.
That is not.
That's like the 19 twenties millionaire.
That's on the cover of the monopoly
game.
Going sociological analysis.
I know lots of people like that and they
work all the time.
All the time from the second they wake
up until the second they go to sleep and
they don't just casually work,
you know,
because I know some of you go to the
library for six hours and you say,
well I studied in the library for six
hours.
Like,
no you didn't.
You study for half an hour,
have coffee,
and you look through facebook and went
home and you said,
well I studied for six hours and you're
happy about it,
but you know,
bloody well you did partly because you
can't,
you know,
I can only read through about three and
a half hours until I'm done.
And I'm pretty good at it.
So these people who are running things,
there's corrupt people obviously,
but the vast majority of them first are
self made.
Its second.
They're so bloody efficient and smart.
You cannot believe it.
And they work 80 hours a week and most
of them happened to be mad.
And why is that?
Because there are a small number of
insane men who will do nothing but work
80 hours a week.
And no matter where you put them,
if you put them in the middle of a
forest with an ax and all they would do
is run around chopping down trees.
So the issue isn't why aren't there more
women in positions of power?
It's why are there any men insane enough
ever to occupy those positions?
You know,
because we also know and the on this,
it's very clear what's the relationship
between money and wellbeing once you
have enough money to keep the bill
collectors from your door.
So once you have enough money to stave
off misery,
which is sort of lower middle class,
something like that in our society,
maybe a little little lower than that,
extra money does not help you.
It does not improve your life.
So why bother with it?
Well,
that's what the women in the law firms
think.
It's like most of them,
by the time they're in their thirties,
aren't married,
almost all of them are married to men
who make as much money or more than they
do because that's what women go for,
cross culturally four to five years
older,
equal or higher in the socioeconomic
status.
So their,
their husband's already made $350,000
a year.
It's like they think,
well I don't need much more money.
The man used money to keep track of the
competition by the way,
because all the male lawyers that I
talked to,
her usually real hard ass guys really
low in agreeableness,
really high in conscientiousness,
like conservative types,
low in openness as well and they want to
win and the reason they care about your
damn bonus at the end of the year isn't
even so much because of the money.
It's because they got a much bigger
bonus than the other son of a bitch
sitting beside them and they're happy
about that.
So there's a real,
like a real brass knuckles competition
that drives these sorts of things.
But we get things backwards so often in,
in,
in psychology and in sociology.
It's not why there aren't more women in
positions of power to whiting.
Any men want those positions,
you just have no idea the amount of
responsibility that comes along with
that.
You just imagine for a minute trying to
run a billion dollar corporation.
You can't even bloody well balanced your
checkbook and there's dust bunnies
underneath your bed.
How in the world would you ever run a
billion dollar corporation?
Those things are complicated and you
have enemies and they're trying to take
you out all the time.
You look at apple and Samsung,
man,
they're just torturing each other in the
courts nonstop.
You know,
you'll,
if you're,
if you're running a big corporation,
you'll be.
You'll be handling two or 300 lawsuits
at a time and that's just,
that's just nothing compared to the
complexity of what you actually have to
do.
Stay on top of the technology,
constantly interact with your large
customers.
Travel all the time because you have to
maintain the relationships.
You have to regulate the politics inside
the business.
You have,
believe me,
it's no picnic and you think,
well,
they get a lot of money.
It's like,
what makes you think that such a good
thing?
You know,
like if you're a half crazy and you have
a lot of money,
you're going to be crazy a lot faster.
I can tell you that frees you from all
sorts of constraints.
You know,
we know the data on lottery winners,
they're no happier a year later at some
of them are done,
especially if they had had like a bit of
a cocaine problem to begin with because
you know,
being stops you from dying.
If you're a cocaine addict,
if you get enough money and the way you
go and you think yourself,
you know,
you've got all sorts of bad habits.
Weirdnesses.
If somebody dumped an infinite of money
or you,
what makes you think you would unravel
completely?
It's highly probable.
So anyways,
so back to these women know what they do
when they're 30 is they look around and
they played hit partner so they'd hit
the pinnacle of their profession.
They think,
what the hell am I doing this for?
Why would anyone in their right mind
want to be woken up at three in the
morning and Sunday by?
They're irate Japanese client who wants
them to work for the next five hours
nonstop to fix this damn problem,
which is going to cost them $100,000,000
right now.
Or we'll find someone else to pay $750
an hour or two to fix it right now.
And you think,
well that's,
you know,
a masculine form of value that.
Because that's one of the criticisms.
If the law firms just adopted a more
feminine structure of value,
it's like,
what kind of bullshit is that?
The reason,
the reason that you get up,
it's three in the morning on Sunday two
to talk to your Japanese client who's
freaking out about their contract is
because if you don't jump the hell up
and do it right now,
there's some starving associate who's
unbelievably ambitious in New York.
Or pick up the pieces and two tenths of
a second and they're smart and
aggressive and they'll take you out.
So it has nothing to do with masculine
structures of values.
All the foolish ideas.
And you know,
it's not just law where this happened
to,
you know,
we know for example,
that female doctors were far fewer hours
too.
So the more female doctors you have,
the more doctors you have to have.
And I'm not complaining about women's
priorities.
I'm not saying that women are wrong,
not at all.
It's like the older I get,
the more I understand that marriage and
family are a primary importance and the
more I see women in particular know they
hit 35 or 40 and they're not married,
they don't have kids and they are not
happy because what the hell are you
going to do from the time you're 40
until the time you're 80,
you got no family,
you got no relationships.
What are you going to do?
Go Run your company.
Yeah.
Well if you're one in a thousand that
will satisfy so you bloody well better.
Make sure you're that one in 10,000
and you're probably not because those
people are rare.